okay thank you very much uh good evening
good morning good afternoon whatever it
is where you are situated
it's uh nine o'clock in the evening in
Portugal where I am
uh I'm delighted to be able to join you
today to talk about uh how we have
implemented a training program in a
biomedical research institution I'm
given my perspective which is obviously
a European perspective it's not a
hundred percent
it's not a generalized European
perspective because it's very much my
own perspective and my experience from
something that I will tell you about
I would like to to thank the organizers
for giving me this opportunity and I
also want to send special thanks to my
fellow course organizers uh Luis antunes
and Andrea Costa a lot of the things
that I will be telling you about today
we have really worked out together and
without this team this hasn't been the
course it is
who am I uh I am a researcher and a
group leader of a laboratory animal
science group at Institute for molecular
and cell biology in Portugal it's
one of the larger
publicly funded research institutions in
in Portugal
my background is I've got a degree in
animal science and a PhD in ethology
animal behavior and Animal Welfare
that background is actually in
agricultural animals but I've been
working with laboratory animals since
2001. and my research interests are
animal behavior and Welfare in research
and research animal ethics
and I'm also coordinating training for
researchers in our institution and also
uh
with some activity external to the
institution and I've been doing that
since 2005.
and it is an activity that takes up
quite a bit of my my time and my
attention and I'm I'm have
I I do enjoy it and find it important
foreign
so I'm going to try to see if we can if
I can get a
all the options of the technology you're
working because I would be curious to
see if I can
uh I would like to know who you are
while listening to me right now so I'm
going to try to run a poll with you
which is supposed to appear right now
okay I think I hope you can see it
and I would be very thankful if you
would answer it by indicating which
professional roles you have if things
are the way I wanted them to be you
should be able to select several
and I see people are pushing buttons
here so you are responding which is
great
I'll just let let this go a little bit
so that you've got the time to
to answer
okay let me see if I can
give you the results
okay we've got three researchers seven
technicians seven Educators ten
veterinarians and 10 others or maybe
some of these are really combined in in
several people
in in the same person sorry
uh
I've tried to do the
next one because I'm also curious to
know where you are
so if you could just choose the region
where you work
that would be great
okay uh most people in Canada in the US
a couple of people in in Europe and
Latin America and one in Australia and
one in Asia okay that's great
it's great to to know
okay in this talk uh I will talk about
uh two challenges that we have been
facing in in our working setting up
training how to set up a relevant and
internationally recognized training in
laboratory animal science in a context
of little tradition and how to meet the
need need for training new scientists
coming in continuously into the research
institutions
I'll share a couple of my opinions with
you and I would also want to you yours
and we should have
quite a lot of time for for questions
and discussion in the end of the talk
so to give you the background on
laboratory animal science in Portugal
uh during the last decade 2000 to 2010
uh Portugal increased massively its
investment in in research it's Public
Funding for research
and during this 10-year period there was
about a 400 increase in research Project
funding
which obviously corresponds to an equal
size or maybe even bigger increase in
number of people working in research
substantial proportion of them in life
sciences research for their animal
experiments come in as a possibility
before
2004 uh there was regular training in
laboratory animal science in only one
single institution so it meant that no
more than 30 scientists a year could be
trained
and in 2005 faced with this challenge
the competent Authority
decided to to issue provisional personal
licenses for researchers that had a
substantial experience in working with
animals
these licenses were issued for two or
five years depending on how
large how long that experience was
and in 2005 when I started to work with
this
um we had
20 such provisional licenses only at our
institutions to which obviously one need
to add at least another
30 or 35 people that didn't have enough
experience to get a provisional license
so needed basic training right from the
start and then we needed to provide
training for those people with
provisional licenses who actually did a
child formal training and also whose
licenses would
would expire within a shorter period of
time
so that was the first challenge we Face
how to provide training in this context
also when people were not used to having
this training available and or to look
for it because it hadn't been available
uh we wanted the training to be relevant
for the researchers so that we wouldn't
have to chase them down to take the
training we wanted the training to be
internationally recognized so that we
knew
uh that our students going somewhere
else would still be able to get to have
their training recognized by the
competent authorities or institutions in
other countries
and also we wanted to build on and to
develop our own competencies so we
didn't want to buy this in we didn't
want to set this up on our own
since we're in Europe uh
it was very obvious for us to look at a
philosophy recommendations which at that
time at least were the only formal
recommendations for training courses
and both Luis and Tunis and myself had
taken a philosophy category C course in
the Netherlands so that was the sort of
the format that we had looked
um
that we had experienced ourselves and we
decided that the category C course would
be what's best match our
uh institutional needs at a point and we
also wanted to draw on collaborations
that we already had so we looked around
uh among the collaborations we had
who had a great experience in organizing
training and we invited
the team from Copenhagen Axel Cornell
Hanson and Dr Bratt bus service and to
join us and they helped us out with the
first couple of courses that we
organized
the philosopher category categories
which probably many of you know about is
directed for persons who are responsible
for directing or designing procedures
it's an 80-hour course
combining Theory with practical
exercises and
at least in the setups of the course
that I know of also a lot of group
assignments
the course curriculum has eight
categories
biology and husbandry microbiology and
disease health hazards and safe
practices design and conduct of animal
experiments
anesthesia analgesia and experimental
procedures alternatives to procedures on
animals ethics and legislation and
Analysis of scientific literature
uh if we view those categories in a bit
of a different way and also at least
with an attempt to portray them in the
with the the dimension with the amount
of time that we we dedicate to them in
the training
they cover
three main aspects of using laboratory
animals or of training people that use
laboratory animals the aspects that have
to do with doing good science the
aspects that have to do with
taking good care of animals and the
aspects that have to do with uh meeting
the expectations of society
regarding good research practice and as
you see of course these overlap a lot to
these different these three spheres are
not at all isolated
having
I started to give these these courses we
quite soon actually wanted to step up
our ambitions
so we looked at accreditation as a way
to guarantee quality and recognition of
our course and we wanted to ensure
National recognition we wanted people to
be convinced that this course would meet
International standards and that it was
actually being checked for that
and again we also wanted to to
strengthen the recognition of the
certificate for our training students
when they went somewhere else so we
looked at the philosophy accreditation
again at that point it was the only
accreditation program
existing for this kind of training and
it still is I believe
uh it sets the minimum requirement for
having run two two courses before
applying for accreditation
so we could apply in uh January 2007
then we had completed two two courses
and you more or less that we would use
the same setup
to get the accreditation uh involved
quite a bit of paperwork
uh matchup with which obviously is
beneficial for the course planning
because it means taking taking your
course seriously working out all
important aspects of it
the paperwork to be delivered is a
presentation of the course program in
quite a lot of detail the teachers and
their qualifications presentation of the
examination methods and also a
presentation of the student feedback
that had been obtained in the previous
courses
after having submitted that uh
we waited a few months for response and
then entered into I think what what I
would rather describe as a dialogue with
the accreditation board
because obviously as I think happens in
most cases there were things that they
thought we could explain better and I
also think they they told us we could do
better
so it took it took us two rounds of
changes to uh our setup of the course
and in our case these were the most
substantial ones were to expand the
amount of practical training
and it took in all around 12 months for
us to complete the accreditation now
this is obviously our experience and
I understand that this must possibly
take this could take more or it could
take less depending on how much changes
are needed and how long it takes for the
course organizers to to bring about
those changes
working under the philosophy
accreditation we've now got five years a
bit more than five years experience of
that our first affiliation period of
five years expired last year and we're
just entering our second five-year
period
and during this period period we have
been submitting annual reports of
courses organized and students approved
of the change it's introduced of the
examinations and also the student
feedback
uh we've paid 385 Euros per year plus
five euros per student certificate
issued so this is for for each student
that passed the course
and there is also a site visit for
five-year accreditation period and we've
got one uh I think three years ago
this is what working under the
accreditation has been on on peer on
paper uh but in practice of course both
the reports and the site visit has
involved a quite a lot of um
quality assessment external and internal
a lot of us looking at how
we do things how they work and how we
could do them better
and I would say that the course that we
run today is the result of our
continuous work to improve largely
stimulated by the accreditation
and stimulated by the accreditation in
two ways
through direct feedback from the
accreditation board and especially
during the the site visit
and the site visit was one the entire
day during one of our running courses we
had two members of the accreditation
board spending time with us spending
quite a bit of time going through
paperwork
uh that we our archives of of stuff
uh quite a bit of time talking to
students in the ongoing course and on
with previous students and also quite a
bit of time talking to us
but the other the other source of
stimulation to to keep up the
quality assessment and quality
improvement has been
through student feedback and the
accreditation has been very important
also through that because because of the
large Focus that large emphasis that
they place on on student feedback
so the course uh that we have today that
I will now talk to you I would like to
talk to you a bit about the course and
I'll talk uh also about the student
interactions that I think that we are
are that have been very important for us
and I think is the strength of our
course
the teaching approach that we use today
this has been changing but this is the
approach we use today and we plan to use
for the the near future
is what is called the Blended learning
approach
uh meaning that we combine e-learning
with traditional lectures with practical
classes and with the protocol
preparation which is a group assignment
that runs across the the two-week course
we run the course
as the two week continuous course there
is of course a weekend in between but
it's not a modular course it starts on
one Monday and it ends on the the Friday
the the week after
e-learning is one of the latest changes
we've introduced into the course we
introduce it uh in response to student
feedback
to give the students better control of
the time and to optimize the use of
teacher-student contact time
so that we would not spend valuable
classroom time with uh International
specialist teachers talking about very
basic aspects so the e-learning is
provided through
um the basic the basic training is
provided through the e-learning
mechanism focusing on or developing the
e-learning platform also meant that we
expanded the course site the website we
use for the course quite a quite a lot
so there we now include the e-lescence
the e-lessons are self-contained uh they
are interactive as far as this is
possible so to make the learning
experience or the studying experience
more stimulating but also to allow
back to students leave a footprint in
the platform so that we can see that
they've actually been each individual
students have actually been into the
lessons and completed the lessons and as
I said the lessons provide introductory
content
uh to almost all top topics with the
more advanced and the more applied
context content being delivered in a
classroom lecture that comes later in
the course
we also centralize all the information
that students need for the course in the
website so that's where they can go and
get the lecture handouts if they want to
print them or if they want to download
them for the future
and that's where we post changes and
updates that happen during the course
so that saves us concerning a lot of
emails uh to to students it's useful in
that way as well
the lectures as I said they focus on
more advanced content and as far as
possible we have internationally
recognized Specialists giving the
lectures
uh generally we have uh people who have
at least a PhD in the relevant topic
with only a couple of exceptions and
another important standard that's not on
the slide is that uh for all the the
lectures and also teachers of all kinds
in this course where this is relevant
and they should have completed the
philosophy course themselves
and I think the only exception we make
for that is for the teachers of
statistics and of legislation because
they have a different background and
they wouldn't make sense for them to
take a live animal science course
the practical classes are animal
handling we've got two sessions for that
that's been a tricky one because uh
we've learned over time to learn to deal
with
people's fears and people's uh
unwillingness to to admit so that they
are afraid of handling laboratory
rodents the way we thought we've found
out is the best way to go about it is to
have two sessions one which is very
simple and very well we don't demand
more than let the students touch the
animals get familiar with them and learn
to lift them in and out of the cages
and it is only in the second handling
class of a ask to be able to restrain uh
um welders and we also offer a
facultative extra practice for those
students who don't uh
seem don't feel confident enough after
those two handling classes to move on to
the next week where they will have to do
procedures of animals
uh
so the two fast sessions are on live
animals
uh the two first points here are live
animals the necropsy the the dislocation
is obviously on
euthanized animals and the suture
practice is um
Alternatives so we try to consider the
three R's in our practical classes
reduction by using Surplus animals from
the Animal Facility that would be
euthanized anyway
replacement by the secure practice
without animals and refinement by
practicing procedures on anesthetized
animals the students obviously need to
learn to restrain live and awake animals
but they will practice injections and
and so on on anesthetized animals that
are euthanized after the practice
the protocol preparation and
presentation I think this is uh quite
common on philosophy courses or that I
know uses this approach the project
consists in preparing a complete
protocol for a research project
we tell the students as if it was for
them to be to present you to an ethics
Commission
and they walk in groups of uh four to
six
the projects are presented and defended
orally during the last day of the course
and the students get to hand in the
corresponding PowerPoint file on day
before we don't ask them to do more
paperwork because they got about two
very intense week and we don't want to
create unnecessary work for them so
that's why we we are happy with the
PowerPoint file that they they need for
the presentation anyway
and we schedule around 20 hours
across the timetable for the protocol
presentation preparation time
elimination uh consists in individual
written exam on the last morning of the
course and the protocol presentation on
the group assignments in the afternoon
of the last day
we have a minimum requirement for an
average of 60 for the two components and
none of them below 50 percent
and we also have obligatory
participation in e-lescence and
practical classes and we have tutors
that assess that the students are able
to perform the techniques in the
practical classes
the students get a certificate if they
fulfill the requirements
and with this certificate the students
need to apply to their respective
competent Authority for licensing so the
course is not an automatic driving
license for this it keeps the the
certificate needed to obtain the driving
license
we also ask students right from the
start to give us feedback so we hand
them out feedback forms on the first day
and ask them to keep on filling in the
feedback as I've been going through the
uh the classes or the different
exercises that different practicals
uh and engaging with students is
important for us because it makes the
course more rewarding for all of those
involved it helps to maintain and to
improve quality it's improv important
for the accreditation
uh each compost a responsibility
engaged students learn more and we want
these calls to be
for the for as many students as possible
we want this course to be perceived as a
resource that is something more than the
minimum learning to get a license
and because we also sell this course
outside our own institution and we sell
places on the course in our institutions
because customer satisfaction and
marketing is obviously also plays a role
for us
we have used those detailed course
evaluation questionnaire since the start
of the course but as we've been running
the course for a number of years we also
increasingly engaged directly with the
students in in smaller groups
we use the course Revelation reports uh
very much we summarize the student
feedback we share it with teachers we go
through them and discuss them in detail
between the the three of us Luis Andrea
and myself
so that we can consider changes that we
need to introduce for our next edition
of the course and we send a summary both
of those reports and of the changes we
want to introduce to the to the
philosoph meditation coming to where
we'll do the annual update of
information
changes that we have been introduced
during the period that we have been
working with this uh well there are a
couple of things we have learned that we
don't change anymore we've got the same
critiques every year and if we do it
what if we do it one way we get one type
of particular criticism if we do it the
other way we get another type of
criticism
um we always get a few students who
think there should be more animal
handling and more procedures and then
we've got another few students that tell
us that it's it is sad that so many
animals are used in this course and we
could respect the three hours more in
the in the Practical training
and we also get students every year
telling us they want more statistics
but statistics is already right now the
discipline has got the most hours in the
course curriculum and when we offered
uh a specialized course in statistics
for animal experiments we got less than
10 people taking the course so I'm not
we are not quite sure what people really
want but we have come to the conclusion
that we can't really we can't do
anything else in the course that we'll
be doing right now
then there are things we adjust
continuously
uh which is the duration of lectures and
overlaps because as people as sometimes
we change lectures or sometimes the
content change this needs to be adjusted
uh every year
and a major change for us that's paved a
way for much more engagement whilst the
introduction of e-learning that freed a
considerable time for targeted teacher
contact with students the learning now
provides about 25 of the theoretical
content
and one of the things that we were able
to start doing with uh when we had free
time through e-learning was this to have
tutorials with the groups during the the
group assignments
the group assignments pick up 25 of the
course time and it's 50 of the
Examination for the students so it's a
very important part of the the course
and we felt it was important that we
engaged more with the students so that
we made sure that the students engaged
with these group assignments so we now
do this spending two times 20 minutes
per group
uh we do two tutorials I do the one the
first one on the first week around
Wednesday in the first week
uh where I sit down with every group to
discuss how the proposed projects relate
to each student's interests and own work
and try to get a feel for the group
dynamic so that if there is something
that really doesn't work if there is a
group which really doesn't work uh we
can do something about that uh while
it's still possible to do it we're still
only on the third day of the course
um the
second week tutorial is run by Luis
Antonis at that point uh that's a week
later the students are already well
ahead with their group assignments and
they've got a number of specific
questions that I want to write right
they want to raise uh since Luis is a
specialist on on anesthesia and
analgesia they would want to discuss
what anesthetic protocol would be the
best for their experiment and there were
also maybe a lot of of other more
general questions so they they like to
discuss
and uh Luis that week also gets an
overall view of how the project is
proceeding if by any chance there would
be a project that is very far behind
there would still be a couple of days
for the the students to catch up and
that we would be able to do something to
tell them that they need to
speed up their work
our Impressions from running those
tutorial uh are that the Foster tutorial
is essentially detect critical problems
with group composition
we need to balance different degrees of
experience and stubborn us the worst
possible scenario is to have one very
experienced and very uh very stubborn
very strong-minded person and then
inexperienced people in the group
because that means that the group will
all run with with the leader and there
will be little room for the the others
to interact
uh We've also found that this is very
stimulating uh for us we got very
interesting discussions with the
students we are talking science with
them and we are actually talking science
with them
already in the first tutorial they they
start to have
scientific considerations on how to
design their experiments and bring up
those questions with me what kind of
treatments groups do they have should
they have
sham groups or do they know don't they
need sham groups Etc
and we our impression is that we've got
much improved project protocols
presented in the end they are much more
complete and uh much more sophisticated
and we always learn quite a lot from
seeing those project protocol
presentations
so overall this is a very positive
experience
with more time
freed we also we're also able to invest
more in
more close accompanying
more closely of companioning the
students
in the practical classes so we've got
one tutor who follows the same group of
three to five students along the
practical classes and you can see this
on the on the figures we've got the
secure training on top figure and we've
got the um
uh dissection training on the bottom
figure so the students are always a
company there is always someone for them
to ask they don't need to shout across
the the
room to get the teacher they don't need
to wait for a teacher who's with another
group
and the tutors are able to identify
students difficulties that need to be
addressed so the tutor sits down
after the training the Practical
training session when they still
remember what's happening with students
I had and they check boxes uh to see for
the demands of practical competencies
and decide if there is a student who
eventually might need some extra
training who might need to be approached
for some extra practical training
okay this is the philosopher category
sequels it's a course for people who are
quite uh high up in the activity on
running animal experiments they are
responsible directing designing
procedures we have trained so far since
2005 417 such researchers
initially we had very senior researchers
those with the provisional licenses I
mentioned in the beginning
uh presently as those senior researchers
have been trained uh we now mainly have
postdocs and PhD students in the course
but of course these are not all the
people who need training these are not
all the the
Parcels involved in research who needs
training and that
um takes us to the Second Challenge
which we have faced uh more recently in
the last three or four years
with this the need to provide basic
training frequently
this because there are new researchers
coming into the institution throughout
the year there are new PhD students
there are new master students there may
be someone
who has not used animal models before
but now their research
a line has taken such a turn that they
want to start to work with an animal
model
uh
and there is a need to ensure that these
people know enough about animals and
enough about how to carry out procedures
in order to minimize animal suffering so
that I can be able to walk on their own
in the
uh in the Animal Facility they are
allowed to do Hands-On work with the
animals
these people need basic training and
they also need this training to be
available frequently because they cannot
move on they cannot get started with
their work before they've got this this
training and most of the times they want
to get started with the work yesterday
because they've got this bright a great
new idea and they've got this mice being
shipped in and now they want to start to
to work with them
um okay would you just hold a second
here
hello
okay excuse me there was a problem with
the line but I think I think it's
it's okay
yes okay
sorry about this I'll get back on track
so the the
facing this challenge of providing basic
training and frequently we were able to
draw on our experiences that we used in
setting up the category C course
obviously we would look at the
philosopher recommendations again now
it's category B
uh that is for persons carrying out
animal experiments and the
recommendations is 40 hours of
theoretical and practical training
and we use this to set up our
introductory course in laboratory animal
science where we use a combination of
e-learning we deliver almost all the
theory through e-learning
then there are taught practical classes
with technicians from the Animal
Facility and from our training center
and then there is future LED practical
training
and all these aspects are important for
the course to be available frequently we
we have a course every three months so
four times a year
uh the course got to be able available
frequently because it's a requirement
for the Animal Facility to give access
to the entry in the facility is that the
students have taken the course
and the combination of e-learning and
the tutorial-led Practical training
makes it possible for us to give the
course frequently because e-learning
takes very little
investment from our sliders Educators
and the tutor-led Practical training is
the students working with a trained
tutor in their own research group in
their own lab
so that's not a burden on the training
center but it's it's shifted to the lab
where the uh the researcher comes from
okay uh we've got another almost 20
minutes and I'm all I'm I'm done with
the part where I'm going to talk
directly about our course and I'd wanted
us to share a couple of of use with each
other and I'm going to share my opinions
with you but I don't want to color your
opinions by mine so I'm going to start
by asking uh for your opinions
and uh I'd start to ask you
to indicate what kind of training of the
four Alternatives that I've given here
that you think best meets the training
needs of an early stage researcher for
example a PhD student who is starting to
work with animals and who will mainly be
doing procedures in animals so Hands-On
work with with animals
uh training on the job with researchers
supervisor training on the job with a
technician or veterinarian supervisor of
In-House course or course organized by
institutions with specialized competence
and I'm just waiting while you're
filling this in
you're still filling this in
okay I'm going to push the results
so uh the majority vote is for training
on the job with lab animal technician or
veterinarian supervisor uh but with uh
41 41 34
of course organized by the institution
with specialist competence
uh 13 for in-house calls and 10 for
training on the job with the researchers
supervisor
then I'm going to ask you uh
to indicate would you think best suits
the training need of a person who has
experienced in animal research animal
based research and who plans research
projects with animals
so not only Hands-On work but actually
project planning
training on the job with more
experienced researcher training on the
job with veterinarian or animal
multiplication no need for further
training in-house training in-house
formal training or formal training
organized by the institution with
specialized confidence
okay I'm gonna push the results for you
okay so I can see that your uh
there is a clear preference so in both
the situations for training on the job
with the veterinary environmental
technician and formal training by a
specialized Institution
uh
quite a few votes also for training on
the job with a more experienced
researcher
uh and
some support for no need for further
training and in-house formal training as
another opportunity
right uh so the way that
I see this on Ice probably with with my
eyes probably colored by the the Palazzo
recommendations uh we are looking at two
types of people who need training people
who know previous training or experience
who will start to work with animals and
people with previous true experience and
training and who will have a more
a wider responsibility not only to
perform procedures but also to plan
projects and I've called these training
needs for basic and for uh advanced
and I'd argue that people with no
previous training or experience need to
know basic aspects of animal biology and
basic aspects of procedures with animals
because quite a lot of those people uh
may have a background in the Life
Sciences but they may know very little
about other animals than humans little
about their physiology a little about
their biology about their behavior about
their their needs and their functioning
and they need to learn
uh about species they work with and they
need to learn that a raft is not a
little human but it's completely
different animal
and of course they also need practical
training and procedures if they're going
to start to do practical uh procedures
this training needs to be available
frequently at
uh
a relatively low cost so that a lot of
people can take the training and so we
don't get into a situation where only a
couple of people in lab go to training
and they are supposed to train the
others
and it is also it also in my opinion and
this this is the part where I'm sharing
your opinion with you it's really what
I'm saying now is what I think with the
experience that I've got
uh that this kind of training needs to
be integrated into the functioning of
the specific institutions so while
they're doing this training uh ideally
people should also learn how the Animal
Facility works and learn to get to know
the people there and and how to interact
with a veterinarian and with the
technicians in the Animal Facility
and I would argue that the local
veterinarian and Animal Welfare officer
is very well placed to to take to
deliver this course and if you will see
a cat passing the webcam now you'll see
a cat's tail at least I apologize for
that
uh I'm at home not at work that's that's
why the cat is here
um so this is for the basic training for
the uh Advanced Training is has to have
a wider scope in my view it needs to
consider all aspects of laboratory
animal use including statistics science
and Society
ethics and project planning so no not
only down to the bench down to the cage
level work with animals but the whole
a set of considerations around research
with animals
this training needs to be advanced in
the sense that
it should
it should fit you into a PhD student
training program it should not be more
basic than that
it should uh in in the in the Logics of
that it should be given by Specialists
who can have who know who are up to date
with the the present level of knowledge
and the present research in in their
respective fields
and because of that uh sorry I'm
escaping flights here because of that
it's probably not something that uh most
that a lot of Institutions will be able
to uh deliver themselves because it
takes a different uh faculty takes a
different set of teachers to do it
we clearly need both because we've got
both these groups of people and many
people many persons will be passed in
the left-hand group and later on in
their career they will be in the right
hand group they will start with no
experience and if they stay in science
and in
uh inducing animals they will be people
start to plan research and they will
belong to those that'll be more advanced
training and we also know from papers
that come out uh every year
what happens when people don't have
sufficient training we know that we have
people who don't use don't use
appropriate
amounts of or approaches choices of
analges again the statistics we know
that experimental design is sub-optimal
we know that
their their shortcomings in the
understanding of animal biology and all
this has an impact
on the welfare of the animals and on the
quality of the of the science so there
really is a challenge to provide the
right training to avoid as much as
possible
uh that these kind of uh sub-optimal
practice sub-optimal practice research
happens
so the take-home message uh
but I would like to give is that the
challenge is to set up training so that
it is perceived as a resource worth
investing in not an obstacle or an
obligation or a minimum requirement that
has to be filled
uh I'm not saying that we've necessarily
been able to meet that challenge fully
uh but I hope that we've gone at least
some way towards it
and I hope that you also wanting to join
us on this this way and from our own
experience I can tell you that you can
go you can go a long way combining
motivation wise use of existing
resources and expertise and a
willingness to listen to students and to
adapt training to to their needs
uh for more information about what we do
uh
there's an email address
uh on this slide
where you can contact us if you would
want to to know something specifically
or interested in collaborating
and you've got a website address on the
slide and you've also got a website if
I'm able to push it from the
uh okay you've also got
I'm also see if I can show
it to you or you can click on it and
connect to it you've got to web links in
the presentation as well
and I will take you to this uh home page
this this website which is our training
website
and if you click
on any of the options here you'll learn
more about the courses that we've got
and if you click on the
um
on the
it's the bottom right corner setting up
training in laboratory animal science we
can help you you can also learn about uh
offers the resources that we've got that
we have developed for people who want to
develop their own training with some
support in in areas and disciplines I
say where they have little expertise
and uh we've got some seven or eight
minutes for uh asking questions so would
you please ask the question and ask the
use the the chat function of the
question and answer function to ask
questions
and I will
look at them and
uh and I will read them out to you I've
got a question that was raised sometime
during the session uh what topics that
we consider to be basic training and I
think I have partly answered that
uh in that this is
what people really need to do when uh
they really need to learn if they've
never worked with animals and if they
know very little about animals so basic
aspects of biology and about taking care
of animals and basic aspects of
procedures
I've got a question here about
uh how this training program will change
with the new European directive
uh requirements of let me see if I can
read the full
question okay how this training is going
to be to change with the new European
directive requirements well this is a
new challenge for us and I haven't
included it here because we are still
trying to follow the the recommendations
to We are following trying to keep up
with the the recommendations that
they're being developed by
uh the working group
it works with the European Commission
and to discuss how we can integrate
those into in our training what I see
very clearly
uh what is coming out of that discussion
right now is two things it's a greater
focus on species and we welcome that a
lot we run a course I didn't say that
but our courses is completely rodent
focused and that's great for people who
will do rodent work it's not so great
for people who do Wildlife Research or
or a large animal research as there is
no other course in Portugal at Preston
so they will come to to our course so we
would welcome the the
possibility to do species specific
courses and we are already working on
that on the B course
another
uh change with the directive is a
greater focus on assessing
competences and qualifications and on
uh practical qualifications and I think
we've already gone quite a bit towards
that in our course with the tutor work
but we obviously we need to especially
in the the basic course where we let the
students have part of the training with
Tutors or research groups we will need
to invest more in how to prepare those
tutors and also how to assess the
students
uh most courses are aimed to use rodents
what about courses on zebrafish and
other Aquatics did anybody who really
implement this well actually we are very
lucky because in Portia there is a great
uh Research Center for aqua for marine
research and they've developed the
philosopher category sequels with which
we collaborate
sorry flask Academy course so there's a
40-hour course focusing exclusively on
marine organisms
uh and uh I think that's excellent and
that's really very much needed
and if anyone is looking for that course
I can also provide the uh the contact
details with that
um
okay
and and and as I also said there are
also other species training needs that
are different from our rodent uh based
traditional rodent course and and I'd
very much like to start to see to see
Wildlife Research courses being
developed as well as maybe agricultural
animal courses in many places they are
they they they don't exist right at the
moment so that's a need
okay I think that was
the questions
that I've been seeing coming in right
now
I'd like to thank all of you very much
for being being here with me today uh
this is the end of the seminar here's my
email address if you have more questions
and uh you've got the email address for
more information about our training
opportunities as well as websites a
couple of sites for the back in the
presentation and these slides will be
available after the conference as well
so you will be able to come back to them
uh thank you very much to the audience
thanks thank you very much to the
organizers this is the end of this
seminar bye-bye